per oggi facciamo una roba nuovissima
quindi happy with many dati sugli
episodi normale 161 quindi abbiamo fatto
160 l'ultima volta che madonna per
finire quel livello non mi basta una
vita
ritorniamo a livelli normali la prossima
volta farò non so se ci prova a fare
quello dell'altra volta però mamma mia
se non avete visto del bisogno della
travolta guardatevelo preferì
incredibile iniziano col primo di oggi
che un album foche sarebbe tipo
l'esperimento uno spy col solo con gli
arpioni
vedi mamma che studiare mi è servito
manie legge su breaking ball run addio
dall'araba tipo la miley cyrus parte che
gli spetta scriverebbe breaking bowl
però fa niente però cosa vuol dire per
chi vorranno cielo saltare quando la
palla mi colpisce lo devo correre ceco
corde o saltare devo arrivare in modo
tale che da saltare tutte le palle hanno
capito un casino devo farmi dare una
botta di quello curtis che dalla palla
per famiglia davanti se ho capito ma
quante soro è possibile se devi farmi
fare una run fa per a fare gola bici
perché quel poco che sarà sta roba
vecchia vacca ok questa è una buona buon
risultato ragazzi sono proprio forte a
volte quel prima di arrivare al finale
volo però vedere se con la bomba resca
fare ho superato le spine quindi credo
che c'era qualcosa non c'era niente dopo
le spine fa niente se ha messo la bomba
immaginavo l'avessero messa per qualche
motivo invece invece nostro è molto
difficile suo livello ragazzi è la prima
volta che vedo una wrecking ball run
sinceramente quindi non denota una
difficoltà in questo livello se mi
impegno ce la faccio ragazza magrebina
guarda tira ok ok è giusto è giusto
adesso non schiantarti roba ragazzi è
più difficile di un impossible cioè fare
sta roba qui con le breaking bole pd fip
grazie a tutti anni e anni di skill non
c'entra per niente la fortuna sono stato
proprio bravo
grazie
no veramente livello bellissimo a mio
parere cioè non avevo ancora visto un
livello fatto c'è la prima volta facendo
avrei kimball lo sbaglio run dice
profondamente figo boltro for good
return balls credo che quella roba di
tele faccia di tornare suo credo che
quello mi ammazzi pure però va beh devo
andare su win solitamente che sta lì
quindi non è così
non è così non è non è così difficile
non è così di imporsi ok tira là davanti
porca vacca ma è così la testa la testa
su in ma non ci può salvare awin ma lo
vedi che non ci si può arrivare a win
ragazzi impossibile non c è
stavo scherzando lo chiamo avanti jones
in affari da un'altra mossa di wrestling
che non è una mossa di bellezza di mai
tirare una sedia al padre di duke va
bene posso anche farlo senza sedia suo
livello
anzi la sua sedia poi mi lancio io ho
afferrato un'altra sedia
non so cosa ci sto facendo in questo
livello 9 9 9 99 per cento impossible
teoricamente teoricamente difficile però
essendo gli fossimo nel cielo è un
grande esperto di questa incredibile
disciplina chiamata impossible
teoricamente dovrei non riesco non aver
capito dall altro appartamento non
perché mettono le bombe tra le mettono
cope e allora cosa nemmeno le mettere
proprio che che ti servono ora scavalca
inutile gli fanno girare le balle con
queste robe occhio e proprio livello
difficile non è che vorrei dire però
anni di vita mi hanno insegnato a fare
le cose
io grazie a detti viso rimorchiato un
sacco di volte fa strano dirlo lo so non
vorreste vivere nel mio stesso mondo lo
so perfettamente nemmeno io vorrei però
è solo così che funziona così funziona
che chi fa l'impossibile rimorchia basta
basta pensare che i muscoli non servono
un calo specie di giocare happy with am
see block chiusa un rapper a minecraft
mycup di bocchino direi propri di
minecraft win due loculi novella la
torta che teorico e la torta questa sì
più un blocco ok ma l'arci green cioè fa
ma dai
si è fermata tra easier win win io non
ho parole
cioè vabbè adesso non può entrare di
niente perché mi ha bloccato proprio la
io non ci voglio io non ho io non ci
voglio credere
io non ci guarda dove si è fermato con
quanta probabilità potrà fermarsi così
ragazzi la mia vita fa schifo la
halloween e ciò abbiamo subito e che
sono proprio difficile a tirare sti cosi
gli zero ho vinto il wing una vittoria
più fasce proprio vinto dove credo
faccia win perché la is here we non ti
dà la vittoria va bene a non proprio
calibrato sto tiro
veramente fantastico schivando gli
uccelli che potrebbe essere molto
deviante come titolo ma facciamolo hamas
o proprio uccelli sono quelli angri
perso che va bene ma io dove vado c'è
una bomba dove devo andare esattamente
che non è che mai spiegato bene c'è una
direzione cioè qualcosa direction gioca
tutto bastano 12 prima dove devo andare
che ci sono successi che già ce l'ha la
monetaria come la prendo come prendo la
moretta commettendo parte che verde ne
va beh devo saltare fortissimo in alto
praticamente doveva tirati dal muro
ovvio la bomba la prendiamo la bomba che
dinho si è rotto il pogo non mi è mai
successo in tutta la mia vita di epic
visto che tutti i beni che ho fatto
nella mia vita di a che mai mi si è
rotto il fuoco però provo una tattica
diversa ragazzino come funziona dai per
niente se riuscisse ad aggrapparmi sul
cosa sto vedendo cose strane come se
riuscissi ad aggrapparmi all'uccello non
pensate male a quello blu mentre vado in
avanti teoricamente dovrei aggrapparmi
di e tenere trova talmente veloce che la
vedo politici la prova che la pratica lo
verde a quello rosso va bene va bene lo
stesso meno recente
scherzavo non va bene
[Musica]
ho provato mille modi poi sono riuscito
nel modo più strano
va bene andiamo avanti ragazzi spyphone
ragazzi non sono mai anche se gli skimen
uniti non è mai così perché ci avete sta
roba di mettere le breaking comunque
però che mi distraggono non sono mai
veramente easing scherzavo questo era
veramente una cagata però tranne questo
non lo sono mai super mario land di
bolle che dovrebbe essere a un mio dio
ma davvero ma funziona tipo che
schiaccia il coso il punto interrogativo
e mi dal fungo mi ha dato la moneta
davvero quindi anche se entro nel tubo
entro in un livello cioè se funzioniamo
funzioniamo per bene che questo non
c'era però la moneta c'era quindi va
bene
belle le palme proprio quello all old
style molto buono e al fungo esatto
biglietto più grosso però me lo fai
prende regione che c'è per caso fammelo
prendere di si può prendere mille nomino
tutto rifugio l'orientale più grosso
però fatto bene ai ragazzi gli diamo i
punti tanto chissenefrega
teoricamente no datolo schiacciato in un
bar importate schiacciarlo lo devo
andare persona monete quelle bellissime
bene ragazzi c'è per l'idea strano che
non sia uno dei veli pd giocate hanno
anzi lo è della settimana però questo si
merita un sacco di play bellissimo ce lo
vedrei un sacco steve come personaggio
non è che dite dei muover pure la
scritta per prendere per il culo non è
che dite era difficile quindi ci sta che
io sia morto non era una cagata suo
livello mai forse rock swing o anche per
me lo è amico mio anche per me non ho
mai fatto uno se questo sarà il primo
vediamo
meravigliosa potevo fare questo nella
gara di rock swing l'altra volta ecco
quella avrei vinto subito 99,7 per cento
impossible meno male che hai messo 7 se
non lo facevo è molto difficile quanto
pare no temo in troppe parti non posso
entrare liberi ma non si può entrare
amico mio avviso non deve essere
veramente impossibile ma poi dico io
vivo allora forse non lo è e molto
difficile però perché come sempre là
dentro perché capito cioè limitante di
altezza come fai a pregare l'arpione
l'ha inventato sata nastro diverse
questo è veramente impossibile
porca vacca raga non mi arrendo non mi
porta rendono mi possa vendere non vi
basta non è da me non è da me per un
secondo mi posso rendere non mi
arrenderò maledizione
madonna la vera soddisfazione mi chiamo
mia madre ed io dico ragazzi facevano un
paio sotto il mio nome perché voglio
vedere cosa succede
abbiamo il file impossible fatto qualche
giorno fa da tommy ciao favi spero ti
piaccia ciao tony
se hai fatto un impossible impossibile
ti odio
no scherzo sono io che devo riprende un
attimo la mano guarda te la dedico tommy
caro perfetta però metti in un box di
meno gli arpioni se riesci facciamone
ancora uno ragazzi ci provo
l'ultimo per oggi di magistero studia
500 ciao caro amico magister hai visto
la mia maturità
[Musica]
no